[Musik]
und darin herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einem neuen blog meine damen und
herren heute eine schöne morgen sowohl
geworden gemeint war die verlosung des
new york - also freunde dieses
berechnete eingeblendet wir finden heute
das bade alltag
youtube an und allgemeine irgendwelchen
leuten raus und dann haben wir das ganz
auf einer website die ich schon öfters
mal in videos benutzt habe und zwar holt
dot net
ich habe keine ahnung dass sie genau an
bevor wir das allerdings machen heute
guten morgen
wir machen uns jetzt erstmal puzzle
fertig
[Musik]
das schmeckt aufgegessen haben wir heute
eine ganz kurze info eben zu diesem pool
ohne wasser ich habe mir 2000
plastikteile bestellt sind leider immer
noch nicht da das heißt wahrscheinlich
im block irgendwann nächste woche bitte
dieses bällebad ihr fertig gemacht und
jetzt fahren wir erstmal in die stadt
die dinge seit einer stunde durch die
stadt noch geblockt
julia hat da ist halt schwer freunde und
spaß diese kinder auf diesem boot haben
einfach eine scheiß hüpfburg ich hab von
amazon tritt gemacht mit meiner familie
und meinem cousin und zu aber wir hatten
nicht so eine hüpfburg auf unserem
schiff holte mir zu denken kinder
hallo keine art und zu dürfen
bild ab so hier am rhein ist schon schön
so die kranhäuser hilft der rhein aber
stinkt aber es können auch sein möchte
ich erst mal erklären warum hier oben im
bau per video eingeblendet die roma in
portugal auspacken um euch das ganze zu
erklären falls allerdings erst mal nach
hause und jule ist dumm
hallo ich bin luca und ich wollte euch
ja erklären warum hier sehr gute
kameraposition luca hallo ihr seht ihr
werbe video eingeblendet weil dieses
video gesponsert wird von huawei im
rahmen des neuen ps plus ich darf das
aber noch nicht fest ob sie kommt und
zwar hat vor einigen tagen einige leute
von huawei jede meiner wohnung und wir
haben etwas abgedreht für den
offiziellen teaser zum neuen huawei ps
magnus und ja richtig gehört meine damen
und herren ich kann
das schauspiel karriere fortsetzen ja
also ich habe in diesem teaser
mitgespielt allerdings habe ich da nicht
alleine mit gespielt sondern auch dieses
ding
das ist klug genug und luca kluge und
ich habe mit diesem teaser mitgespielt
freunde und genug nun seht ihr bisher
nur von hinten allerdings werdet ihr
genug wut auch den titel wir nehmen
jetzt mitgespielt habe ihn zu sehen
bekommen am 28 um 20 uhr auf dem nur wer
deutschland kanal auf youtube
instagram und facebook david livestream
stattfinden wo wie coole challenges
machen werden ihr werdet in dieser film
sehen werde genug nur wenig mit mich
sehen und ich meine wer will mich nicht
sehen also klickt auf den link in der
infobox und da bekommt ihr alle
informationen allerdings seht ihr ja
hier schon genug wo eingeblendet freunde
und da hier ja schon am titel lesen
können war das alter von youtuber also
wir werden heute wieder auf einer
website gehen wo wir bilder hochladen
können von youtube die und sagen hey so
alt sind wir eigentlich wirklich das
ganze werde ich natürlich hier mit
meiner kamera aufnehmen ich werde hier
sitzen und im hintergrund wird ab und zu
genug nur an verschiedenen orten zu
sehen sein also jetzt kommen wir zum
eigentlichen inhalt dieses videos zum
wahren alter von youtube allerdings
könnt ihr ja dann einfach mal in die
kommentare schreiben wie oft ihr genug
nur im hintergrund gesehen hat
[Applaus]
also sind die website hier aus anholt
dotnet wir können hier beispielsweise
war einfach im foto aussehen wie der
lacht doch ganz süß hier klicken einfach
mal auf use this photo und wir sehen 36
also der typ auf diesem foto wird von
dieser website aus 36 jahre alt
geschätzt er könnte jetzt beispielsweise
auch irgendein anderes foto aus wir
nehmen wir beispielsweise man hier den
vater mit seinem sohn da wird gesagt der
sohn ist sechs jahre alt der vater ist
51 schon gehörigen abstand bei vater und
sohn allerdings sind wir ja nicht hier
um irgendwie und solche beispiel bilder
anzuschauen sondern wir schauen wie alt
youtuber sind das erste foto das ich mir
ausgesucht habe meine damen und herren
von einem youtuber den ich sehr sehr
gerne schaue den ich über krass
respektiere wo ich wirklich sagen muss
die video ich selbst ja und ich werde
auf 21 wenig geschätzt was also ich bin
22 das ist richtig nah dran wenn wir
gerade schon von mir hier reden meine
damen und herren würde ich sagen dass
wir als nächstes foto einer person
nehmen die mir sehr sehr nahe steht und
zwar juli und das ist eine freundin von
jude ich werde das foto jetzt auch mal
auf der webseite hochladen und wir haben
24 bei jule und 27 bei ihrer freundin
ihre freundin heißt jona und die wohnt
gerade für zwei drei tage bei uns also
die werdet ihr gleich auch in meinem
blog sehen auf jeden fall wird juli hier
auf 24 geschätzt ihre freundinnen auf 27
wir klicken auf try and other foto es
muss seinen freunden wie wir ist so der
youtuber schlechthin in deutschland auf
die website sagt 27 ich glaube die ist
sogar so um den dreh als ich hab früher
so krass häufig diese hole dot net
videos hochgeladen also wo ich mir
einfach immer die da irgendwelche bilder
aus dem internet herausgesucht hat von
irgendwelchen youtube an et cetera pp
hab diese fotos auf dieser website
hochgeladen um dann einfach zuschauen
wie alt die geschätzt werden
allerdings habe ich als nächste person
jemanden vorbereitet hier bzw
ein foto von dieser person rausgesucht
bei dem ich selber vor einer woche
zuhause zu besuch war
ich find meinen richtig scheiße riskiert
hier auf 28 geschätzt
ich glaube rob ist 23 deswegen soll ob
diese website denkt dass du älter wirst
du wirklich bist und zwar ganze fünf
jahre
aber ja nächste mal ständig den falten
kleben
passend zur ob natürlich auch jemand den
ich sehr sehr gerne mag und 27
simon will haben wir hier kunst die tags
any faces okay ich und du hast
anscheinend kein gesicht allerdings habe
ich natürlich direkt ein weiteres foto
hier vorbereitet falls ein foto nicht
klappen sollte deswegen simon du wirst
auf 28 geschätzt ich weiß nicht wie alt
simon ist aber ich glaube das kommt in
einer gewissen form hin als ich meinen
auf dem foto hat er hier auch irgendwie
runzelt die stirn
wir sehen hier den bart und so weiter
und so fort also daran macht die
webseite das ja fest und ich glaube da
kann man der werkstatt zur zeit scheint
ich bin echt gut im reden jedoch würde
ich sagen machen wir direkt weiter mit
einer person die ich in letzter zeit
erst entdeckt habe und zwar moritz ist
ich glaube der ist eigentlich so 17 oder
so ich glaube auch von den usern nicht
ausgesucht habe ist nur moritz
tatsächlich jünger als ich aber er wird
auf 25 geschätzt das hätte ich nie
gedacht gerade wegen so wie hier das
gesicht und rote bäckchen und so
allerdings habe ich als nächste person
jemanden ausgewählt der
unterschiedlicher eigentlich nicht sein
könnte als moritz justin meine damen und
herren also justins fotoladen werde sie
auch mal auf der webseite hoch und wir
haben 25
ras
justin ist ich weiß nicht wie alt 20 21
oder so ich mein ok websites ist es
jetzt das nächste foto das ich
vorbereitet habe ich glaube jeder weiß
dass es sascha ist also unsympathisch tv
und sascha dein foto werden wir
natürlich auch direkt auf der webseite
ich hoffe dass sascha dieses video hier
nie sehen wird allerdings würde ich an
dieser stelle jetzt auch das wahre alter
von youtube beenden meine damen und
herren der blog wird gleich natürlich
sofort direkt normal weitergehen wir
werden gleich etwas essen gehen aber
schreibt ihr mal und in die kommentare
wie oft habt ihr genug nur im
hintergrund gesehen also an wie vielen
verschiedenen orten hat sich dieses
kleine monster hin hier versteckt bei
mir im hintergrund wir gehen jetzt was
essen
doch noch nicht essen denn es ist ein
paket angekommen mit diesem inhalt das
heißt das kommt jetzt die reihen mit dem
magischen sand drin als das bällebad ist
fertig freunde so sieht das ganze aus
nach trotz trotzdem 100 entspannt ist
das essen freunde ich habe gerade ein
neues mixtape aufgenommen für mein sound
low profile habe dass ich auch gerade
schon hochgeladen
falls ihr also bock auf solche mutter
hat oder falls ja allgemein mal hören
möchte was ich hier so für mucke
produziere als ich produziere nicht ich
mixe vorhandene die da zusammen zu einem
großen mixtape oder team kommt
vielleicht bald dann kommt vielleicht
auf meinem zimmer bleiben kann dich
selbst nicht selten das darzustellen da
wird dann irgendwo anders hin aber ich
werde den weg machen und das produzieren
wenn ihr euch das ja die frauen hören
wollt freunde dann ist eine beschreibung
dieser moment erinnert mich einfach an
diese kinderspielparadies
diese rein und raus es ist schön einfach
ein 22 jähriger der sich ein bällebad
ins wohnzimmer gestellt hat allerdings
habe ich mich immer ins bällebad gelegt
weil ich euch glaube ich doch gar nicht
gesagt habe warum ich hier bei gesagt
habe haye für das psn plus mache ich
natürlich gern werbung face 1,3 zoll
display und fassbar leistungsstarker
akku effekt bei bildern hier kameras und
das ganze bei einem krass heftigen preis
leistungs verhältnis also das waren die
gründe warum ich wirklich gesagt habe
weiß ja ich habe bock darauf mit euch
zusammen verwalten dieses handy wird
heftig hier allerdings zu beginn bereits
gesagt wie können bälle bitte in meine
tasche kommen die bereits in diesem
video gesagt werde ich euch das handy
zusammen mit einer moderatorin und cool
challenges und einem live stream
vorstellt ich glaube er ist langsam dass
es am 28
um 20 uhr auf den hof weiter nähren
instagram youtube facebook stattfindet
aber sonst sonderling in der
beschreibung und wir gehen jetzt schnell
zu essen schnitzel
ja wir einfach dass es allerdings will
ich an dieser stelle im heutigen doch
jetzt auch beenden meine damen und
herren ich geschlafen weil ich bin echt
müde
[Musik]